pour le gouvernement trudeau les cieux
ont déjà été plus clément souvenez-vous
d'il ya quatre ans le début de mandat de
justin trudeau était ensoleillé même à
l'étranger
mais un autre voyage on a fait déchanter
et la plus grande tempête restait à
venir avec la sphère snc-lavalin et
l'expulsion tardive diront certains jodi
white ribbon reaching justin trudeau a
perdu d'autres alliés plusieurs de ses
homologues provinciaux ont été remplacés
par des premiers ministres réfractaires
à sa taxe sur le carbone l'achat de
pipelines n'a pas apaisé les défenseurs
de l'industrie pétrolière et à irriter
bien des environnementalistes justin
trudeau et c'est maintenant de regagner
le coeur des électeurs en rappelant son
bilan allocation canadienne pour enfants
légalisation de la marijuana
renégociation de l'alena
que ce soit dans le cadre de la laine la
ffg ou du nouveau partenariat
transpacifique nous avons obtenu des
résultats considérables sans jamais
compromettre nos valeurs évidemment il
ne se vend pas de l'abandon de sa
promesse de changer le mode de scrutin
ou d'équilibrer le budget dans un
premier mandat
mais d'autres se chargent de le rappeler
aux électeurs surprise le budget n'est
toujours pas équilibré
quand andrew scheer a été élu à la tête
du parti conservateur en mai 2017
plusieurs croyaient que justin trudeau
était destiné à décrocher un second
mandat
le paysage politique a depuis changé
difficile de faire des prévisions sans
risquer de se tromper
au cours des derniers mois enzo scheer
n'a pas ménagé ses critiques
ces attaques je demande à justin trudeau
de démission il veut maintenant insisté
sur ce qu'il a à proposer y multiplie
les discours mais l'enjeu de
l'avortement et cet ancien prises de
position sur le mariage entre personnes
de même sexe sont récemment revenu le
hanter
ça soulève de graves inquiétudes
c'est cette déclaration qui a fait dire
au chef du npd qu'il ne pourrait pas
appuyer le parti conservateur dont
l'éventualité d'un gouvernement
minoritaire
comme quoi les néo-démocrates se résigne
déjà à penser au scénario de représenter
la balance du pouvoir au fil de départ
électorale le npd est en position plus
précaire qu'il y a 4 ans en 2015 thomas
mulcair semblait avoir le pouvoir à
portée de main le rêve lui a glissé
entre les doigts et six mois plus tard
les militants du npd lui montrer la
porte
on sort 10 et unis
son successeur john meeting peine à
remplir les coffres de sa formation
politique
il a parfois fait preuve d'une
méconnaissance des positions de son
propre parti
il a été élu dans une élection partielle
mais devra maintenant affronter une plus
grande bataille
[Applaudissements]
tout comme lui et indochine
yves françois blanchet se lance dans sa
première campagne en tant que chef
son parti a aussi connu sa part d'ennuis
en février 2018 des déchirements
internes ont incité sept des dix députés
a claqué la porte du bloc québécois
mais le départ de leur chef martin
ouellette après le verdict sans appel
des membres du bloc a permis au caucus
de se ressouder
je vous annonce donc aujourd'hui que
j'ai quitterait le poste de chef du bloc
québécois
[Applaudissements]
l'arrivée dit françois blanchet a été
bien accueillie par les députés rien
n'indique encore que le parti soit sur
le point de retrouver des résultats
semblables à ceux d'avant la vague
orange mais les bloquistes rêve quand
même de faire des gains versés par
l'idée que les peuples du canada
quelques mois même sur les propriétaires
de nos lits aux docks
la chef des verts ale on sera à sa
quatrième élection avec l'environnement
qui s'annonce l'enjeu central de la
campagne le parti se fait davantage
remarqué elizabeth may s'oppose vivement
à l'expansion du pipeline trans manten
et a été arrêté durant une manifestation
elle a doublé la députation font partie
au parlement depuis l'élection d'un
deuxième député vert le printemps
dernier
maxime dernier lui est encore seul à la
chambre des communes
il a tourné le dos aux conservateurs
qu'ils étaient passés si près de diriger
et ne les ménage plus ce parti est trop
corrompu intellectuellement et
moralement pour être réformé il
multiplie les déclarations choc sur le
multiculturalisme et les changements
climatiques co2 en tant qu'elle n'est
pas de la pollution si on se fie aux
intentions de vote son parti populaire
n'a pas encore suscité de grand
engouement et joue donc le tout pour le
tout les heures sont comptées les 39
prochains jours nous diront vers où le
vent va tourner
[Musique]